it's the crack of dawn somewhere near
stuttgart and cecile le con is getting
ready for work
the anti-nuclear activist is planning a
day of climbing and protesting
cecile sets off in a convoy with the
rest of the environmental protesters
they organize today's action via encoded
emails
they want to be in position before
sunrise with their blockade of the
nuclear power plant at nikah best time
every minute counts
together the activists erect a barricade
they hope will stop the 300 power plant
workers during their shift change
french-born cecilia used to climb for
medals in sports competitions
now she climbs for her political ideals
it's her way of making a point but
there's also a safety aspect
i feel safer in a tree or up in the air
than down on the ground
they can't get to you as quickly
i've been at sit-ins where the police
start whacking people with batons
sometimes without warning
if you climb up somewhere the police
can't reach you easily it's a lot safer
they'll think a bit more about what
they're
doing the barricade is up in an hour
cecile and the others want to see neca
best time taken offline immediately and
not in a few years as planned
for cecile it's not just a question of
belief it's her job
she's a full-time activist and this is
her work
i do it because it's worth it
they're not going to shut down the
nuclear power plants unless people do
something
everyone should do this till we reach a
critical mass
not the critical mass in the nuclear
power plant but here on the street to
get everything switched off
the anti-nuclear protest movement has
occupied the road here even if it is
just temporarily
the plant operators and the police are
taking a passive approach letting the
protest go ahead for cecile a small
success on the way to a greater goal
i won't vote for politicians to spend
four years breaking their promises i
want environmental protection and
nuclear phase out from the grassroots
in berlin there's an annual meeting for
all those who support cecile and other
full-time activists it's an opportunity
for sponsors to contribute money so the
former teacher can dedicate herself
entirely to protesting
i found cecile's commitment so
fascinating that i said this work
deserves my support
i can't do all this myself so by
sponsoring something like this i can
make a small contribution so someone
else can be active
cecile gets the media attention to make
things a success
you wouldn't get that attention if
cecile wasn't there climbing up trees or
chaining herself to things
there is no talk about money here
for cecile it's just enough to pay her
living expenses and social insurance
i think resistance movements work a bit
like a chain and every link in the chain
is important
financing is one i look for my own
sponsors
people who feel like supporting my work
are welcome to those who don't want to
anymore don't have to
it's up to them
and that's how she's ended up traveling
around germany as a freelance activist
for the last few years
like here in dortmund
the climber turned activist even uses
her court summons as an opportunity to
protest against government policies
her activism is a delicate balancing act
between upholding and breaking the law
she's been summoned to court for
barricading a ship transporting nuclear
waste last year
for cecile that represents a world
turned upside down
a number of activists have turned up to
support cecilia
she's got a host of arguments planned in
defense of her action
she's using the courtroom as an
opportunity to explain the reasons
behind her anti-nuclear activism
she's not afraid of convictions or heavy
fines
i've been convicted a few times on
public order offenses like for freeing a
field from genetic engineering
i sold that fine i said who thinks it's
right to make a stand against gene
technology
forty people bought a day of the fine
and it was paid off
cecile's barricade of the nuclear plant
at nicaragua's time won't have legal
consequences though the operators are
allowing the protesters a free run and
the police have opted against clearing
them out
the workers are using side entrances
instead
it's a small victory for the
anti-nuclear camp and for cecile it's
just the end of another shift working as
a full-time activist
you